Cette photo du Che,
Che Guevara,
vous la connaissez tous.
Elle a été imprimée sur
des millions de tee-shirts.
Elle a été prise
il y a tout juste 63 ans,
ça fait longtemps.
Et pourtant,
elle reste un objet culte.
Comme cette photo,
d'autres clichés sont devenus
iconiques avec le temps.
Le portrait d'Albert Einstein,
la photo de Marilyn Monroe
au-dessus
d'une bouche de métro,
le déjeuner en haut
d'un gratte-ciel ou encore
la photo de cette jeune
afghane aux yeux verts.
Toutes ces photos
ont une histoire
que nous allons vous raconter
avec Lauren Malka.
Lauren vient de rejoindre
la team Epicurieux.
Elle adore la pop culture
et vous allez le voir,
elle a le don de dénicher
des infos surprenantes.
On commence tout
de suite avec la photo du Che.
Cette photo d'Alberto Korda,
est la deuxième image la plus reproduite de l'art occidental
après "La Joconde".
Et dire, qu'elle est restée
dans les tiroirs du photographe
pendant presque 7 ans,
et surtout qu'elle
ne lui a jamais rien rapporté.
Pas un sou.
Voilà son histoire.
Nous sommes le 5 mars 1960
à La Havane.
La veille, un cargo chargé
de munitions pour Cuba
a explosé dans le port de La
Havane.
Bilan, presque 100 morts.
Pour le président Fidel
Castro,
aucun doute, c'est
un coup de la CIA.
Il décide donc
de faire un discours
pour rendre hommage
aux victimes.
A quelques mètres de lui, en tribune,
se trouve Alberto Korda, chargé de le photographier.
Mais, toujours à l'affût, le photographe repère Che Guevara qui s'approche
de la balustrade
pour contempler la foule.
Ni une ni deux,
Korda a juste le temps
d'appuyer 2 fois sur son appareil
avant que le Che ne disparaisse.
L'instant dure moins de 30 secondes.
Il présente les photos
à son journal
mais celle du Che n'est
pas retenue.
Il faut attendre
le mois de juin 1967
pour qu'un éditeur italien,
Giangiacomo Feltrinelli,
tombe sur le sésame.
Il demande son prix à Korda.
"Cadeau" lui répond
le photographe.
L'italien qui est un homme d'affaire très futé,
embarque le tirage
et le transforme en poster non signé,
qu'il vend 5dollars pièce.
Et là, c'est bingo !
Quel flair !
En effet, quelques mois plus tard,
le Che meurt, assassiné
par balle en Bolivie.
La photo de Korda fait alors
la une des plus grands journaux du monde.
La photo est même imprimée
sur des t-shirts.
On en fait des tirages posters
qui se vendent
comme des petits pains.
Le cliché est même
sérigraphié par Andy Warhol.
Mais le plus incroyable
dans tout ça, c'est que jamais
son auteur ne réclamera
le moindre centime.
Alberto Korda meurt en 2001,
sans regret.
Pour lui,
ce cliché n'était,
comme il le disait lui-même,
qu'un coup de chance.
Deuxième photo, je l'adore celle-ci.
Venez.
C'est la photo la plus célèbre
d'Albert Einstein.
Je suis sûr que vous
la connaissez.
Mais peut-être pas
son histoire.
14 mars 1951.
Einstein vient de fêter
ses 72 ans dans le New Jersey.
Il est tard, il veut rentrer
mais c'est déjà une icône à l'époque.
Une horde de journalistes
l'attend à la sortie
pour le photographier.
Il rejoint ses copains,
dans une voiture,
et affiche un air ronchon pour qu'on
arrête de le paparazzier.
Jusqu'au moment
où l'un des photographes,
Arthur Sasse, lui crie :
"Un dernier sourire pour votre anniversaire, monsieur Einstein."
Agacé, Einstein le regarde droit dans les yeux et lui tire la langue.
La photo est exceptionnelle
mais à l'agence
on hésite à la publier.
On a peur de vexer le grand génie.
Finalement, l'image
est envoyée à la presse
et se retrouve
en une de France Soir.
Albert Einstein n'en tiendra pas rigueur
aux photographes et à la presse.
Il adorait l'autodérision.
Et puis, derrière ce geste,
il y a un vrai message
qu'il va lui même décrypter.
"J'ai toujours
eu de la difficulté, écrit-il,
à accepter l'autorité.
Et, ici, tirer la langue à un photographe qui s'attend à une pose solennelle,
cela signifie que l'on refuse
de se prêter
au jeu de la représentation."
Point à la ligne.
Cet acte de rébellion
n'empêchera pas Albert Einstein
d'en commander
9 copies à Arthur Sasse.
Il en dédicacera
même un exemplaire
à un ami journaliste,
qui sera ensuite vendu
aux enchères, au prix
tenez vous bien,
de 74324dollars.
Preuve qu'une belle grimace
vaut parfois
plus qu'un joli sourire.
Pas mal, hein ?
Enfin, tout est relatif.
Allez, suivante !
"Déjeuner en haut d'un gratte-ciel".
C'est le titre de cette photo
culte qui représente
des ouvriers américains
cassant la croûte.
Ils ont l'air de se détendre,
comme au comptoir d'un bistrot,
alors qu'ils sont assis
sur une poutre qui surplombe
Manhattan,
sans aucune sécurité,
à plus de 240 mètres
au-dessus du sol.
S'agit-il d'un simple trucage ?
Pas du tout.
Ce cliché a été pris
le 20 septembre 1932
pendant la construction
du célèbre Rockefeller Center.
Les ouvriers sont
de vrais ouvriers
qui travaillent
sur le chantier.
Par contre,
il s'agit d'une mise en scène.
On a demandé à ces 11
maçons de sourire
et de prendre la pose
pour une publicité
qui paraîtra dans le "New York
Herald Tribune".
L'objectif : vendre des espaces
de bureaux dans ce building.
Mais ce qui est encore plus vertigineux,
c'est le contexte historique
de ce cliché.
Nous sommes au lendemain
du krach boursier de 1929,
une période de crise sociale
et économique
sans précédent aux Etats-Unis.
On appelle cette période :
la Grande Dépression.
En fait, le milliardaire
John Rockefeller,
qui construit ce complexe culturel et commercial
veut faire rêver les américains.
Et il entend le montrer
avec une image de travailleurs
heureux de bâtir
la future capitale du monde.
Sauf que
la réalité
est beaucoup plus sombre.
Les 11 hommes présents
sur l'image,
font partie des 4000 ouvriers payés
1,50dollars de l'heure
par le milliardaire.
C'est un salaire de misère
pour l'époque
mais ils n'ont pas le choix.
Ils préfèrent risquer leur vie
plutôt que de pointer
au chômage.
Pour info,
il faut savoir qu'un ouvrier sur 10 en moyenne
effectuait une chute mortelle par tranche de 10 étages.
On a retrouvé le nom
de certains d'entre eux :
Sonny Glynn, Matty O'Shaughnessy,
Joseph Eckner, Joe Curtis.
Pour la plupart, ce sont
des Irlandais immigrés.
Aujourd'hui,
les New-Yorkais considèrent
que ces hommes font partie
de leur propre famille.
Allez, photo suivante.
Si Marilyn Monroe
est une icône intemporelle,
c'est en partie
à travers cette photo.
Je devrais plutôt dire
à travers ces photos
car elle n'est pas unique.
Il en existe des dizaines
prises le même jour
par une foule de photographes.
Elles ont été prises
en septembre 1954 à New York.
L'actrice y tourne
le film de Billy Wilder,
"7 ans de réflexion."
Avant le tournage,
Billy Wilder
fait appel au photographe
Sam Shaw
pour créer l'esthétique
du film.
A la lecture du scénario,
Shaw repère une scène dans laquelle
Marilyn se promène dans la rue
et marche au dessus d'une grille de métro
qui soulève sa robe blanche.
Ce sera l'affiche du film, dit-il.
Histoire de faire le buzz,
le photographe organise
alors, à New York,
un faux tournage de la fameuse
scène,
auquel il convie toute la presse.
Plusieurs centaines de journalistes, des photographes et des fans de Marilyn
sont au rendez-vous
pour voir la robe de Marilyn
s'envoler au dessus
de la soufflerie.
Les photographes présents
ce soir-là
sont tous convaincus
qu'ils ont accès aux coulisses
d'un tournage historique.
Dès le lendemain,
les photos sont publiées
à la une de tous les magazines.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là,
mais vous allez le voir,
cet épisode va avoir
des répercussions inattendues
dans la vie de Marilyn Monroe.
Se doutant du battage médiatique
que va faire cette photo,
plutôt osée pour l'époque,
la robe s'élève au dessus
des genoux de la star ;
Joe DiMaggio,
son mari,
entre dans une colère noire
et frappe
violemment Marilyn au visage.
Sa maquilleuse racontera,
plus tard, qu'il lui fallut
des heures pour camoufler
les traces de coups.
DiMaggio ne sera pas poursuivi,
à cette époque
malheureusement,
les violences faites aux
femmes ne sont pas un sujet.
Mais Marilyn blessée
au sens propre
comme au sens figuré,
sera sans pitié avec lui.
Elle le quitte peu de temps après
et décide
de voler de ses propres ailes
en créant sa propre compagnie
de production :
"Monroe Productions"
Allez, dernière photo.
Celle-ci.
Vous avez vu ce regard ?
Hypnotisant.
Prise en 1984
par le photographe américain
Steve McCurry, cette photo
qu'on appelle
"l'Afghane aux yeux verts”,
ou "la jeune Afghane"
fait la couverture du magazine "National Geographic", l'année suivante.
Et on peut le dire,
elle va bouleverser le monde.
Suite à sa parution,
des millions de personnes
se portent volontaires
pour travailler
dans des camps de réfugiés.
La jeune fille est âgée de 13 ans
quand Steve McCurry
la découvre dans une école de filles
située dans un camp de réfugiés afghans à Peshawar, au Pakistan.
Il la sent plus timide
que les autres
mais il réussit
à la photographier.
Une fois rentré à New York,
le photographe est saisi
par la force de l'image.
Un regard intense
et égaré, dit-il.
L'histoire aurait pu s'arrêter là
mais Steve McCurry,
conscient de l'impact
qu'a eu ce regard
sur des millions de personnes,
à travers le monde, décide
de retrouver son modèle.
Il ne connaît pas son nom.
Il va donc chercher
pendant des années.
Et puis en 2002,
il retrouve enfin sa trace.
Elle vit dans l'une des régions
les plus dangereuses d'Afghanistan.
Elle s'appelle Sharbat Gula,
ce qui veut dire
"fille fleur d'eau douce" en pachto,
l'une des langues officielles du pays.
Elle ne sait rien de sa notoriété
et franchement,
c'est le cadet de ses soucis.
Elle vit recluse avec son mari et ses filles dans une très grande pauvreté.
Ce n'est qu'en 2021 que Sharbat Gula
comprend à quel point cette photo
peut changer sa vie,
celle de ses filles
et peut être même
celle d'autres enfants réfugiés.
Aujourd'hui, à plus de 50 ans, après avoir reçu
des propositions d'aide de différents gouvernements,
elle a décidé de poursuivre
sa vie en Italie
où ses filles sont libres
d'aller à l'école.
Un nouveau chapitre, espérons-le, pour une vie plus douce.
Merci Lauren.
Comment une simple photo peut changer notre regard sur le monde ?
C'est toute la force
de ce mode d'expression.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à nous proposer
en commentaire d'autres photos iconiques,
nous vous en révèleront
les coulisses.
Et si bien sûr, vous avez
flashé sur celle du jour.
Lâchez-vous, likez et abonnez-vous, si ce n'est pas déjà fait.
Allez à dimanche prochain,
chers épicurieuses et épicurieux.